oui
l'entreprise a été créée en avril 2014
c'est un restaurant qui se situe à
personne à saint pierre on est à
l'entrée de saint pierre et on l'a
appelée entre terre et mer
avant de créer l'entreprise donc j'étais
demandeur d'emploi ainsi que mon mari
donc on a décidé de créer une entreprise
déjà on était dans la partie de la
restauration on est arrivé à 57 et 58
ans ont trouvé plus de travail sur le
marché du travail et on n'est pas encore
à la retraite
les étapes de la création de la faire ça
a été déjà trouvé l'emplacement après
une fois qu'on a trouvé l'emplacement au
vu du montant des travaux qu'il a
fallu effectuer pour la mise aux normes
on a fait appel à la cci pour la
création d'entreprises dont elle nous a
aidés à monter tout le dossier de
créateurs d'entreprise après on a
présenté notre dossier a réuni
entreprendre pour une partie du
financement en 6 pour les demandeurs
d'emploi et la banque de la réunion pour
l'autre partie puisqu'ils doivent être
les deux prêts doivent être d'égal
montant
en fait le projet a été fait à deux
c'est à dire que mon mari est chef de
cuisine depuis plus de 40 ans il a
travaillé avec des chefs étoilés donc là
une maîtrise haut niveau tout ce qui est
cuisiné présentation et moi c'est tout
ce qui est partie gestion est sale
donc c'est vrai que ça a été un énorme
soutien c'est lui qui a créé la carte
des restaurants ma femme est très tenace
on va dire que quand elle a une idée on
va jusqu'au bout c'est quelqu'un de
calais du caractère aussi et quand elle
s'implique c'est totalement
donc les naisseurs sont locaux après
c'est vrai que pour tous qui et légumes
en passe par une quête à côté donc déjà
au niveau du quartier on peut travailler
le pain c'est aussi c'est pareil c'est
un boulanger qui nous livre c'est vrai
qu'on travaille avec
lille avec les réunionnais voilà enfin
je veux dire cesser de faire la qualité
a un prix
voilà juste
en termes de création d'emplois déjà on
a commencé donc à 3 et au fur et à
mesure du développement
on est aujourd'hui on est six salariés
et trois apprentis du centaure c'est une
grande fierté en fait les tables d'avoir
réussi à créer de prouver qu'on pouvait
nos agents n'étaient pas encore décati
quoi et puis après de donner du travail
aussi d'autres personnes c'est une
grande fierté